hello and welcome to episode 159
of gamespot after dark i'm your host
jake decker uh tamora is gone he let his
insight get a little too high and a
lovecraftian creature picked him up and
now he's just suspended in midair so you
suck don't they still pick you up even
if your insight's not high enough and
sometimes yes i think they do
i don't remember well he's not here to
confirm or deny that so he's trapped in
the menses nightmare yeah he's trapped
in the men's this nightmare sucks to be
him uh but joining me today is jean-luc
seidge uh i am not trapped in the mets
this nightmare i'm trapped in the
current waking world which is might as
well be a nightmare
yeah
this room with this desk that every
episode i will [ __ ] on this is gone
um but john luke is back obviously you
could i'm sure you knew he was back when
like it started and you could hear right
away
uh
even though even though he stole a lens
we'll forgive him because he can get
this get this running stolen lands what
not really
and then also joining is jordan remay
hello very confused what the [ __ ]
stealing a lens what's happening
we talked about it last week but
basically uh richard and i were looking
for this lens this 50 millimeter lens
which is really nice and we couldn't
find it and here we go yeah and it was
in john luke's desk
yeah i uh i left it
to be honest when you found in your desk
i was like oh thank god
[Music]
if it was if it was in someone else's
desk i would have been like
this we need to talk to this person
if it wasn't
no i'm not going to say that if it was
anyone in game spot if it was in their
desk you know that's fine i wouldn't
have cared but maybe across the hallway
you know
yeah you know like you know if it was
like on jan's desk
no i'd be fine yeah
we love jan jan let's borrow so much of
their stuff
um anyway this is
going to be an interesting week uh i
haven't played a whole lot but there's
one game that jordan and i have played
that we're probably gonna roast for a
little bit
uh you can probably figure it out
um we're going to talk about gamescom a
lot happened two days ago a week ago two
days ago two days ago i don't know time
uh so we've got some games we want to
talk about there we've got question of
the week from maria once again and uh
that will probably round out the show
but if you're in chat and you've got
questions along the way firm at us i am
here checking chat
well now i am i wasn't a second ago
but now i am lying to the audience
should we start with what we've been
playing jean-luc do you want to start uh
before the misery begins yeah before we
or i don't know should we just get
something let's get right into saints
row because i want to hear about saints
row no you don't no you don't i do
i love
love
saints row three
it's like easily one of my favorite
games of like the 360 era two and three
i really liked i loved two and three
excellent i even liked four i actually
also like four it definitely like
pushed it to the limit like they kind of
couldn't go anywhere else from there and
then they tried they tried to go to hell
for that one thing and that was terrible
that wasn't very good and then they were
like we're gonna do it in slightly
different reality with agents of mayhem
where it's like and pierce and kinsey
are still here they're just kind of like
different i'm like
this doesn't work as well as you think
it does
agents of mayhem it that game was such a
mess that had the same vibe to me as
like when gearbox tried to make um
battle battle battleborn yeah where it's
like oh it's kind of borderlands but not
really and it's like it's trying to be a
different thing and it's multiplayer
focused and it's no one cares like
i mean yeah it's uh
and then yeah and then they said okay
we'll make a new saints row and
i
admittedly from what i saw i was like
okay this looks very dated uh this looks
like it's probably gonna be
play very similar to three
not great but like i can live with that
as someone who still likes three and i
played that remastered they did a couple
years ago i was like yeah i can do that
as long as the writing's good and and uh
the characters are funny and the game is
stable
i will play it so
sounds like i was maybe a little too
ambitious in what i was asking for one
thing i will say i played on pc
i didn't have any bugs as bad as what
people have been crazy because i have
heard so wild yeah it is bad like i'm
not denying that it is bad
i am simply saying that in my experience
i didn't run into any major bugs apart
from you know characters would pop in
and out there's a lot of pop-in
but you kind of expect that when you
play a game before the first day and
stuff like that game like saints row
like
it's not a rock star game right it's not
a sony game like i expect that kind of
stuff
uh
it doesn't ruin the experience all that
much no other stuff ruins my experience
the the reviewers i've talked to like
dan reichert i'm sure you know people at
gamespot probably have heard his
experience where he couldn't he got like
15 hours in and the game just broke and
he had to start over and he was like
yeah i'm good
um i know skillup had a bunch of issues
talking to him about it
you had issues as well right i didn't
have nearly as bad of issues as most
people have had
xbox i think is probably the most
glitchy out of all the platforms so
i i've had some like
major just characters disappearing
talking to people and they're just not
even there like those types of things
nothing nearly as bad as like the
helicopter arms and like torsos that are
spinning around like i haven't seen 700
degrees oh no it's it's like the
equivalent of like the old mass effect
glitches of like shepherd's head like
turning like multiple like times and
it's
like an andromeda situation so so i
guess what i'm trying to say then is uh
i guess if you really want to play
saints row probably do it on pc not xbox
probably even then you'll probably still
run into a lot of bugs i think i was the
outlier actually i'm very certain i was
the outlier
in this situation but like other than
bugs
the game is pretty
not even lacking because there's a lot
there it's just not
great i actually think the beginning of
this game is
quite good not like fantastic but like
with you the setup for what they're
doing is very good like this idea of
these different people from different
gangs all like happening to live in the
same
like apartment because they're just
trying to make ends meet and they have
like student debt and like all this
stuff and they're just doing their best
and their lives suck so much that they
kind of have to like turn to this life
of crime i'm like this is relatable this
is good not all the jokes are landing
but some of them are like kind of funny
and relate to the situation
a few of them were i thought were pretty
good but then like i think it was right
around the time that you unlock the
church and then start getting to the
more like all right now you're gonna do
a bunch of different missions in a row
that are
different flavors of driving to a spot
and shooting people that's kind of like
where the
game sort of
lost me
yeah yeah i'm kind of with you because
when i started it i mean the
customization's really strong in this
game too i i think
at the very least like i had a lot of
fun
customizing my character and you can
continue to customize your character as
you play the game if you decide you
don't want to be if you don't want to be
a woman you don't want to be a man you
want to be a witch you want to be a
robot like you could just [ __ ] be
whatever you want which is awesome like
that that's cool the car customization
also is really cool
uh there's a lot you can do with that
but like
that's all set that's all window
dressing right exactly i'm actually
surprised that car combat and like car
customization wasn't more
in depth considering just how much
driving you have to do well in this game
because there's a lot of options but the
game at least i didn't finish it but the
game is never like
let's take this time to customize a car
like let's do the car customization
mission that you know like san not san
andreas gta 5 has and like games that
typically have that have but this didn't
which is interesting because they
clearly spent a lot of time on that
um
i don't know but yeah like i would say
the first couple missions i was like
okay like
this is i'm shooting things things are
exploding this is fun
and then i got to a point where i was
like okay yeah like you're saying i'm
just driving from point a to point b
shooting guys and then returning and the
shooting's not great the driving is not
great uh the game doesn't look great i
like kind of like the world i thought
the world was interesting the world is
probably the best part of that game like
i i did enjoy exploring the world and i
liked checking out the desert i know a
lot of people are like they have a it's
a [ __ ] desert but i like thought it
was kind of cool like there's like old
rundown wild west towns that you can
check out
but it's just uh yeah i just and
when you go back and you like look at
saints row the third or even saints row
four like the stuff that you're doing
like even from getting from point a to
point b is like
sometimes so
different and unique and exciting and in
this game i'm like i'm literally just
getting in the same car
over and over and over again and going
to the same missions that are just
shooting over and over again and i there
there feels like there was opportunity
to introduce like more creative things
where it's like oh you're having all
these businesses that like are fronts
for the crimes that you're committing
but it's like you you're not actually
working with the people to clean up
crime scenes like all you're doing is
you're
driving you're driving the body away
from the crime scene and then like
sometimes people chase you and sometimes
people chase you but you're not like
participating in like a mini game to
like clean up the crime scene and i'm
like you could have injected a bunch of
different types of like smaller games
into this so like spruce things up and
make things more exciting it's like
especially because
there are some story missions where you
have to complete a certain amount of
side hustles what are they called i
think so yeah yeah side activities um
and i completed two of them and the the
one actually the only one i no i
completed two of them but the only one
that i enjoyed was uh
insurance fraud insurance fraud
all of them but they just were like yeah
every time
you hit a car it explodes and you fly a
hundred feet in the air and i can get on
board with this
this is entertaining
it's always been fun
but then i did another one and i'm like
i have to do this 11 times i can't do it
i would say yeah the difficulty on that
one like ratchets up so i think like the
first one is like you got to get a
million dollars and then the next one
they're like you got in the same amount
of time i'll get like four million
dollars in like jesus christ like i i
saints row is i think the
first game that i've played this year
and i'm not saying this to be like oh
this game is like absolutely atrocious
it's the worst thing i've ever played
but it's like the first game i've played
this year where i'm like i just
i can't bring myself to finish it i just
can't
do it like i do that with every game i
play but
not for you for the golden ring
but like saints row
i
i fell off saints row not because i was
like i don't know if i have time to
finish this i fell off same stroke
because like
i'm done i i've seen what this game has
to offer although one thing that i
haven't done that i do want to try out
that you have done is co-op right i did
you attacked a lot
we attempted and it i
whenever we tried to join my game it
never worked so maybe it was just
i i i don't know but when i joined
devonte's game it would uh work every
time and it was
okay like i it's not like this it
doesn't transform the experience into
this fantastic thing like the only thing
it really adds is like when you join
someone else's game it's like hey by the
way if you complete this like one
challenge you'll be able to play a prank
on whoever's game you're hosting
sometimes the challenge will be like
kill two enemies from long range or like
uh kill someone with explosive damage
what are the pranks the pranks basically
cause an effect to occur to the host so
like i turned devante one time into a
toilet so he's just a toilet with a
handgun just like running on one time
you like
uh christmas music was playing and like
snow effects were coming off him so as
he was gliding through the air like just
snow was falling on the city
they're just like weird things that like
the host is like what the [ __ ] is
happening to my game because it doesn't
tell the host
that pranks can happen so you don't know
about pranking until you join someone's
game for the first time and then it's
like hey if you want to do this thing
you can do this thing and yeah
that that was fun and like it will like
keep giving you like some pranks to like
do so i had my most fun doing that and
not explaining to devonta what i was
doing
was there any like
progression like did you were you able
to progress when you join someone else's
game or is it
i'll help you with your stuff but when i
go back to my game i'm not getting it
yeah basically it was i would help him
with a mission and then when i went back
to my game that mission was still
incomplete so it's like
he's got money from it i got ex i think
i got a little bit of experience and i
think i did
i think i kept the money
but i can't remember
uh but yeah it's more one of those
things where it's like
do some crazy [ __ ] with your friends
doesn't that sound fun and
i don't know
there are there are other games you can
do that stuff with in like with other
people that i think are better i'm
pretty sure couldn't you do that in the
other saints rows didn't
like four have co-op i think four had
co-op crazy did three have go up thank
you for you might have been okay
it started with two
three okay or i don't know if agents of
mayhem did because that was why i loved
saints row 2 so much when i was younger
because
my cousin would come over with his xbox
and we'd play co-op saints row and at
the time
at least on console it was super novel
to be able to explore
in in an open i mean the world's small
by today's standards but like an open
world with someone else like that was
that was that was dope you couldn't do
that and there was no gta online yeah
and like i think san andreas had san
andreas had co-op but i think you were
tethered and it was split screen it was
a little weird
maybe it's signatures i don't know if
you're seeing anything sandra did have
an online well andreas did have an
online mode on pc that is like a whole
thing but that's like a different thing
but yeah but yes like
saints row i think a lot of the novelty
at the time was like
it was like a gta competitor back when
that still felt like kind of a novel
thing to be a gta clone and like did
enough of its own
like stuff we're like as you know gta 4
was like we're gonna get serious and
gritty and like four is like very brown
and muted and you know it's like trying
to be a serious drama at times um where
then like
saints row two was just like you have a
a car that shoots sewage at people
and that's cool this new saints row is
just too middle of the road and what
tone it wants to go for it's not nearly
dramatized enough with a little bit of
humor like saints road too but it's not
nearly ridiculous enough like saints row
the third or saints row four to be
exciting i was like i would have either
gone like
sunset overdrive levels of
ridiculousness with this reboot or been
like you know what we're gonna do
something like
a mafia saints row to early gta type of
storyline that just has like a bit more
humor in it but like there's just gonna
be like this really interesting story
and sure they're like nah we're gonna
try to like bridge that two gap and like
and you got nothing in the end you got
nothing yeah does it ever reach like the
because if you remember three three gets
real weird
driving around with the tiger driving
around with the tiger
the part where you're singing like
uh you know uh
i think bismarck is four i forget who
what is in three but you're like singing
songs with pierce in the car
zombies show up at one point for like a
mission
but reynolds is the mayor like no it
doesn't do any of that i mean i haven't
finished it so maybe eventually it does
well yeah i guess i haven't finished it
because that was what like really
endeared me to that game like the
gameplay of three is like okay but it's
like it was i remember like really
falling in love with like all the
different characters like kenzie and and
you know pierce and stuff just because
like i found them to be so funny and
likeable
the most ridiculous thing is that
there's some
tech stuff that you can unlock like a
hoverboard this like wall thing that
when you like put it up it allows you to
shoot bullets through it and when your
bullets go through it it can go through
buildings you can hit enemies on the
other side and like this football that
when you toss it into people and they
catch it it like
shoots them into the sky where they
explode so like that's probably the
goofiest it gets where it's like here's
like some really weird sci-fi tech that
you can unlock but that's not really
that out of step with like what was in
like three and four though yeah yeah
it's different but it's not like that's
kind of the weird thing about this game
i would say is that
it's it's clearly stuck in an identity
crisis because it it
it it says it wants to be like saints
row two and one like a little more
grounded and to be fair it is but
that doesn't work if all the characters
kind of suck in the story kind of sucks
and the gameplay is not great right
but then it has those ridiculous aspects
that make me think like
maybe some people on the team were like
no we got to this is saints row we got
to make it ridiculous we got to have a
football that launches people into space
yeah it's like so it it's really weird
and to be fair like i would argue that
the saints row games have struggled with
their identity since the very beginning
i mean it started out as a gta clone
like saints row 3 i think like kind of
finally started to figure it out but it
went so far off the rails that it was
like what is this game anymore i think
each previous saints throw game in my
opinion like the overall franchise maybe
doesn't have an identity but each
individual game did yes like two was
like
okay we're gonna be like maybe one's the
least one right where one was just
trying to get a gta clone like very like
you know straight up two was like okay
we're gonna amp up like the we're gonna
be kind of more like tarantino-y a
little bit i would say where they were
trying to be like goofy but in a very
like violent way like two like
all the characters are [ __ ] awful
awful people but the game is very aware
of it and like uses that i remember that
funeral scene from two when gat takes
the dude responsible for his
girlfriend's death and just puts him
like in like while he's still alive and
buries him yeah or the part where they
take like holy [ __ ] or the part where
they take the girl and they put her in a
truck and then they put that truck in
the middle of a monster truck rally yeah
yeah like
[ __ ] like that like two is wild like in
the beginning of two you like bust in
like a courtroom to break like get out
of like his trials just murder everyone
like and it's like really violent
and they're like oh people like this
wild stuff let's like amp it up a little
bit and that's where you get saints row
the third from yeah third tries to be a
little more like comedic with it and and
but i think it like struck a white
balance and it also did a good job of
in its comedy trying to
satire other games at that time like gta
assassin's creed and stuff like why do
we have to go to this waypoint to unlock
more of the map and it's like ha ha
that's funny why does assassin's creed
make you do that yeah yeah yeah again
just trying to try to like looking at
the trajectory like for gta 4 is going
yeah and being like we can we can kind
of fill this niche for the people who
just like the gta game where you like
hit the cheat code to get the tank right
away like we did that game right and
then like four was just like all right
we'll just be crackdown now which was
like fun as well but then it's like yeah
people want crackdown so we'll give them
crap give them crack down that game
straight up has orbs in it that yeah
building the building i remember playing
that i was like this is better than
crackdown yeah it is it is it's fun and
you know it was a wild game i still have
such fond memories keith davis in it
they make they do the mass effect joke
where you can just make out with
everyone yeah
[Laughter]
did you guys play gad out of hell i
tried and i couldn't it was bad yeah i
didn't i didn't even touch it i was like
i don't understand
what's going on i'm going to give a
controversial opinion within the saints
row community
i think johnny gatt is not actually that
great of a character oh yeah i don't
think so but the saints row community
loves him because they were so mad that
he wasn't in three because he dies but
then it turns out he's not really dead
he got like abducted by aliens and you
save him in four
but i'm just like i i think that's
actually the least interesting character
and then they were like what if we make
a whole game about gat and it's like
yeah i was just like oh this just
doesn't work yeah
i just don't think he's that interesting
of a character he works in two the most
where it's where everyone's just [ __ ]
awful and that's why they killed him in
three because they were like the tone
was like he would not work in the tone
of three at all so it kind of made sense
yeah
anyway it sounds like this game doesn't
really have
as much memorable stuff like that this
is kind of my point right like
here's my thing if if you are a fan of
saints row and you really want to play
saints row just wait
like wait sure at least for the bugs to
get worked out and then the price to go
down because
it has to there's no way it's gonna
there's gotta be a better game you can
play than waiting for things
i mean honestly like play saints row
three four i almost thought about
playing god out of hell while playing it
i was like wow
any of our viewers to give agents of
mayhem i i remember robert hanlery would
always joke that it was his favorite
game of the year and then he'd be like
dude check this out and go over to his
desk and the game would just be glitched
to all hell
because he was so sick
oh
that poor guy yeah i i it
you know it's a follow up to get out of
hell because one of the endings of god
of hell is that
at the end johnny gets to kind of decide
like what happens and one of the choices
he can make is that the universe will be
remade in a way where the saints will
all still be
alive in like their own way okay that's
what agents of mayhem is is the
alternate reality that gatt makes where
you should do a saints row lord i do not
want to do saints row because
in ages of mayhem as like a
as like he was like the dlc character
where it's like
that's like the agents need like a new
force and it's like only one man is like
powerful enough do they do any of that
in this one do they do any nods
uh but i don't know i i didn't finish it
uh i don't remember those games super
well
yeah i don't know
i would assume like insurance fraud just
in the fact that like it was in the
previous ones but in terms of characters
i don't yeah it seems more mechanically
in interviews ahead of time
several devs did say that like this
wasn't a follow-up to those games but
there would be references back to those
games they must be there and i just
haven't i i think there are i think
there are some but i don't think they're
like characters showing up i think it's
references to
uh businesses that may have been in the
older years i mean they still have what
friendly fire is that what this store is
called yes and all of them okay sure
still got that stuff so there are
references there are plenty of
references to it but i mean
there's a whole like history thing about
red faction which is in this thing yeah
man so they tied both games to the red
faction universe there's a red faction
brewing there's a there's a there's a
bar a red faction bar but that's the
other thing about sainsbury's like that
seems really cool i'd love to go inside
can't there's like no interiors in this
game apart from some shops
i know making it and making interiors
and games is really [ __ ] hard so like
i get it but like
at least
a little more so like if you're a little
more alive i'm a little more lived in
like i want to see where some of these
characters
are always saying like
they do such a good job with this world
to your point like it's so cool to
explore this place saints row two i
remember had like a lot of random
buildings you could go into i mean
there's an entire underground mall that
i don't even think was a story mission
like i just found it because you know i
was playing co-op with my cousin and we
just go underground and there's this
entire underground mall actually i think
that may have been documented on the map
because there were stores you go but
like
that didn't serve a purpose but it made
it in the game while like i
wouldn't imagine anything like that
being in saints row because it wouldn't
serve a purpose to the narrative or to
like the level design right
that's another thing like modern game
design i feel like sometimes is so this
is a tangent but it's so like
streamlined that some of that fun stuff
you kind of lose well i was
this is like way outside the scope of
like a game like saints row but in my
head growing up playing games like gta
and three and four like my vision of
like what would be like the future
evolution with better tech and it would
be like a city where like every building
you can go inside yeah like not even
necessarily everything has to have a
purpose but it's just like it just adds
to the level of so basically a larger
like bully where or like a or a lot of
systems in place yeah or like a yakuza
but instead of like one tiny street it's
like much bigger but but like it has
that same level of just like density
where it feels like you can go inside
every shop
this is a little different because it is
but but the witcher 3 pretty much every
building you could walk into sure um but
there's not skyscrapers there's not a
bunch of buildings right you're
wandering yeah yeah and i think even
like some of the bigger cities there
were obviously buildings you couldn't go
into but i i remember when the witcher 3
came out and i thought what you're
saying now it's like i wonder if this is
the next step in open world games is
that these interiors are going to play a
much bigger role and like
red dead had more apparently gta is
supposed to have the most interiors of
any gta game that they've said the new
one at least according i think to
schreier's article they're they're
interesting they had mentioned i would
love to find out what game has the
largest like
map but also like interior design for
buildings like that that's really hard
to make too yeah like making interiors
is so hard i guess like oblivion and
skyrim like bethesda games like every
building you can go inside right like
um every planet you can go on oh [ __ ]
and what's it called uh starfield star
field
that'll be
man i'm so curious
we're going way off tangent now
this is our podcast we're gonna go
wherever we want yeah
um well i think we've talked about
saints row enough one last thing because
i don't think i said it but god do these
characters they're so annoying i every
time they open their mouth i'm just so
sad i feel like some of them have
good potential in the beginning people
do and they just don't go anywhere
it's really corny too the way they
handle their backstories it's like
it's like yeah
i do badass things but i'm also into art
and it's like okay i wish i could say
but why like what got you an art you
can't just say you're into art and then
we're like oh that's a good character
they do so much telling and so little
showing where it's like who is it nina
the one who's like
yeah cars and art and stuff like that
and she was like this game is like a
family to me and it's so hard to leave
them like i've seen
nothing of what you're talking about
they all treat you like jerks and why
have you not left this group sooner or
later i don't know it's so sad that i'm
playing a saints row game i'm like man
these characters aren't exciting which
is like usually that's the thing the
thing that saints row has kind of over
gta like yeah
well anyway that's saintstro
go play it no spend money on it that's
not what we're saying
don't put my name on this
it's jordan's game of the year um
yep anyway jean-luc yeah what have you
been playing
i've been playing
not saints row thankfully um
i've been playing a couple games over
the uh my break i took last week
uh one of them is how do you say it's a
phi messiah dimesia yeah i think so is
that how you say it sure yeah the souls
like that came out on steam uh it's by a
smaller studio i don't know their their
name it's like 25 bucks
it's
it's pretty pretty solid i would say um
you can definitely like
feel the budget of the game kind of
presentation wise um
i feel like that game kind of hitches
and chugs and i have a 3080 ti and i'm
like this game should more than be able
to oh is it like firmly in that like
double a space yeah
yeah like i i do think it has some like
really impressive like art design and
direction but you can just like see
certain things where you're like oh you
got you know you guys didn't have half a
million dollars exactly
exactly like or you know just like maybe
yeah like not quite the
level of polish you'd expect but i i
don't think that like is a detriment to
the game overall just
um you know like
i i guess it's like you naturally will
compare it to a from software game which
just has like
such [ __ ] amazing art direction it's
kind of hard to not in the back of your
head be like oh this doesn't look as
good as bloodborne but it's like of
course it doesn't like duh
uh but what's cool about it is i think
they do some interesting stuff with the
combat where
um it it kind of goes for this i would
say
so your character only has one weapon so
they're kind of going for a
secure like you're kind of learning this
one tool kit but
you'll get these um
things called like oh i forgot what
they're called basically
you'll have
actually let me let me start over
because there's like multiple layers to
this so you have like your basic attack
right and you what you do when you hit
with your basic attack that will um
eliminate their health bar but as their
health bar goes down there will be a
second green health bar underneath it
and
if you leave an enemy alone for a while
they will regenerate their health back
to where that green health bar finishes
at
so you need to be very aggressive you
can't just like hit an enemy like back
away you need to keep attacking them to
get rid of the green health bar you have
to use your secondary heavy attack which
is this like up close claw attack and so
you have to get rid of both health bars
to
actually kill the person so
you find yourself have to be a lot more
like strategic where it's sort of like
uh okay i need to like hit this person
with this attack and then i need to hit
them with this other attack to actually
kill them so even if the first health
bar is completely gone they will still
regenerate like so once the first health
bar is completely gone your normal
attack will start to get rid of the
green health bar okay um but the thing
is is like with bigger enemies where
you don't want them to just keep
regenerating you'll do a tactic where
it's like okay i'm gonna hit you a bunch
with my basic attack and then i'm gonna
hit you with the green attack so you
don't regenerate that and just keep this
fight like that's interesting drawing
out over and over and over and then that
gets more complicated as you start to
fight like any multiple enemies and it's
like okay you want to like strategize
attached to or no stamina um there's no
stamina but um
you have like
um
so one you you have like a combo and you
can you can get like skills to increase
it so i think you can get to like oh you
can attack like five times in a row or
something like that most enemies will
like eventually just kind of like block
your attack after a certain number
um and then attack you back you do have
a like a parry deflect you can do um
as well as a dodge so you kind of pick
between those two
um very secure like again um what's
interesting there also is that they have
these skill trees where you can put
points into
your different systems so you can say
like
i find myself using my claw attack more
so i'm going to put a bunch of points
into the claw attack to have that
function in various ways and you can
actually like change the way it works
where
you can have
uh one tree where it's like okay i'm
gonna give my claw attack the ability
for me to like
rush down and do like three quick
attacks in a row we have to be very
close to do it versus another tree
you can give yourself like a long range
attack where you will like kind of like
jump at them and hit them from a
distance with it but you can only pick
one or the other it locks out the other
tree the cool thing is that at any point
you can refund those points and put them
into another thing at no cost so
yeah so you could just switch things up
like that like this is not working yeah
yeah so i did that during boss fights
where i'd be like
yeah this
i find myself not using this ability at
all i should like put points instead
into
making like the deflect easier so i you
could like make the deflect uh perry
window a little bit like more forgiving
um at the trade-off of you'll do less
damage on your like rebound attack
or you can make it more precise and
you'll do more damage and so like it
i appreciate that they it seems like
that that stuff is there to um
kind of help with like difficulty
uh but also just like lets you
experiment with play styles in a way
that is very forgiving versus like a
from software where you're like oh i'm
stuck on this
this path i took until
i get like invested in faith on accident
yeah yeah
like i don't have enough to respect
everything hopefully i'll find the
respect in 40 hours and maybe i'll
change it up
uh so that's cool
um
you also will get these like special
uh i guess like spectral attacks
um where
you will uh like summon like say like a
spectral hammer that'll like smash down
on it
how you get these is um when an enemy is
all their health is fully down they'll
go into a down state and you can either
kill them or if you like charge up your
claw attack you'll do this move where
you like grab them and you'll like rip
the like i guess the like soul art like
ability out of them
and then you get that move as a
attack that you can use once and then it
goes away
so that's pretty cool though give me
your abilities yeah and it'll be tied
into like what that enemy is so it's
like oh that enemy uses a sword and
shield so when i get it i get this like
shield bash or i'll get like a bow or
i'll get like a a
scythe or something and it's cool
because it's essentially this like free
heavy-hitting attack but you can only
use it once so
you want to again when you're fighting
multiple enemies you want to kind of
like plan out your tactics and be like i
gotta make sure i don't accidentally
kill this guy and i like actually like
rip out his thing so that i can get this
free attack to hit with the other guy
um but you know you have to charge it up
so you need to make sure you don't get
like hit while you're doing it you can
also rip it out of people um uh before
they're dead too i figured out like
halfway through they don't have to be uh
dying so as long as you just charge it
up you can just rip it out so you can
rip it out of like bosses and use it
halfway through which is cool do you get
special weapon spectral abilities when
you rip it out from bosses or no um
actually i don't know if you can rip out
of the the main bosses oh no like mini
boss okay okay there's a bunch of like
mini bosses that um like won't respawn
how's how's the level design because
that's always
the thing that i feel like a lot of
souls like games are lacking it's pretty
solid it's it's nothing amazing but i
think it it has that
uh kind of like
so it's basically a i would say it's
very much um
demon souls like where you have a hub
area and then you will you go you're
going into these memories and they're
like these segmented sections that
you'll go into there's still like
shortcuts and
things that you want it'll be like oh
you know
it's not a bonfire it's a like chair you
sit in but it'll be like oh i there's a
door lock next to this thing and then i
like eventually back around and unlock
the door from the other side and
there'll be like alternate paths you can
go down that usually
lead to uh like finding a cool item or a
cool piece of lore that you can read so
they they're they're they're tapping
into a lot of that they're much more
condensed levels um but
and the game is not terribly long
i'm i want to say i beat it in like
are you tan are you playing it on your
steam deck i am playing it on my steam
deck steam deck's the way to go the
steam deck
[Music]
it's pretty easy
on the steam deck i did have to lower
some of the graphic settings and i was
like it's gonna look a little ugly in
spots but it was playable and that was
cool so i
did your steam deck good because that
that puppy like eats up
some games not that bad i don't know i
can't play original sin two on it not
really just like it's exploding they're
like
too much [ __ ] is happening you're like
causing lightning and fire and yeah 30
characters are moving it's like no
though we're not going to do this
we have an hour of battery life but i
would recommend i'd recommend the game
if you if you like
from software games and you're kind of
looking for a game to like scratch that
itch
while you're waiting for like lies of
pee or
whatever
are you recommending this as in like you
should play it sometime or you're
recommending this in a you should
probably play this before december
because no i wouldn't say i wouldn't say
that like i think it's good
i i wouldn't say it's like this amazing
mind-blowing experience i don't i don't
know if it's gonna end up in my like top
10 or anything like that but it's a good
game and i think like
the you know clearly a small indie team
and like i i'm like yeah like they made
a solid game that i think is worthy of
recognition and if you like these kinds
of games i do think it's worth checking
out at some point
um yeah i think i will i
it's interesting that you said like if
you're looking to scratch that soul's
itch it's it's worth jumping into
because like i feel like i'm typically
not like until until like i don't know
software games like they're some of my
favorite games of all time
but like
i'm pretty content just playing those
most the time you know like if if i
really get the itch i'll replay
bloodborne i'll jump back into eldon
ring
i'll check out demon soul you know like
uh i'm pretty happy just doing that it's
surprising how effortlessly they
dominate that
job yeah it's not like oh call of duty
is just the best first person yeah and
no one else is good at making things
part of it is just like those games
demand so much of you too that they do
that i
when i'm done with them it's like okay
i will i don't know if i want to give
that much of myself to search to yeah to
like the search
and i know that the search 2 is actually
pretty good and people really enjoyed
that game which is which is great but i
i just
yeah i don't know uh
says should i get dynesia instead of
saints row
definitely over st row i mean i haven't
played saints i have not played this
game john luke's talking about like i
feel pretty confident in that um
i will say i agree to your point about
like just
those games are like an event and you
you feel exhausted
this game is very brief and i did not
find it um personally at least too
challenging enough where it felt like
the right amount for me it felt like a
nice little like in-between game um i
think like honestly i thought the
hardest boss was the first boss
and then the other ones i just kind of
like breathe through they also had
harder versions of them you could fight
later that i didn't bother with
um because i just wasn't feeling it but
i think i think i'll definitely try it i
just i don't feel like i'm in a rush to
try it i guess and i i don't think it's
the kind of game you need to go rush out
right away just sort of like hey if
you're ever
looking for a game to play and you could
you're like yeah i could go for one of
those i think it's a cool a cool little
game it's a steam deck game when i get
my deck i have like i have like a dozen
games and i'm like that looks cool i'm
gonna wait till i get my until you get
steamed and then the steam deck's gonna
come right before uh the game of the
year stuff and i'll be like i have to
play like 15 games on my steam deck i
can go to the lamb i'm like i'm waiting
for patches
and speaking of call the lamb i had to
put that on hold because uh the ps5
version of that game is buggy and i kind
of hit like a weird soft lock moment
where oh
all of any time i try to perform any
ritual uh the game just like freezes up
well that freezes up like my character
just like does not move
like they'll do the ritual and then it's
like
and back to the game
and then
my character stands there and i have to
like quit out and i'm like
this is a bummer because i really like
that game that game is great you know we
had talked about it on previous episodes
of the podcast um so i don't have
anything new to say other than yeah
unfortunately that ps5 version is uh
kind of buggy and i
wish i picked it up on pc instead
because it seems i mean you can you're
just going to be out like 30 minutes and
i have to restart and i was like i was
like over halfway too yeah
this way so war games need cross
progression i know really i know that
it's hard but yeah especially because i
was like [ __ ] if i got it on pc i could
have played it on the steam deck in bed
and then like and so i'm like
choices were made
i just
popped this in the microphone
um another game actually i've been
playing on the steam deck is arcade
paradise have you guys heard of this one
i have not it's this little game that
came out that is um are you guys
familiar with these like kind of growing
indie
sort of like
simulator management games that are in
like first person um where
so like
are you guys familiar with like weed
shop 3 or like
internet internet cafe simulator 2. are
you familiar with games like that yeah i
know you're talking about i've seen
those games recommended to me but i
haven't played it i haven't played so so
those games if you're not familiar with
them they're like these weird kind of
like simulation games where it's like in
first person it's like hey you're like
running a weed shop and you like start
in this like shitty kind of like just
like corner of like a building and then
you're like
i spent enough to buy like a table and
then like i'm gonna sit here and like
roll the joints and then like you're
getting money and like people are coming
in and like using your
uh shop and those games are like
the you look at those games and they
look like steam trash they look like
those like weird um
someone in chad mentioned power wash
maybe power washes i would say kind of a
different game
power wash is like a simulation game but
it's it's very
laser focused where those games are more
trying to be like a management sim
because it actually has like things like
you're earning money and you're like
keeping track of like you know you're
doing a job just in a video game yes
you're basically doing a job in a video
game do you need help john literally
well
where we simulator works is that like
it's also very weird
and has like a lot of humor to it i'll
be honest i actually think a lot of the
humor in those we like weeds shop
specifically is kind of juvenile and bad
some of it's funny but some of it i'm
like okay this is
actually very juvenile have you seen the
trailer for bloody hell hotel no god the
game looks so cool it looks my game
looks so cool but it is a simulation
where you're a vampire right it's a
vampire i think so you're a vampire who
manages a hotel
and that's all right
and apparently apparently the issue is
like you have to feed but also you can't
feed on everyone because they have to be
able to survive to give good reviews so
more people come to your hotel i
will absolutely be playing that the art
style looks insane too like it looks
really cool okay cool yeah i'm i'm on
like a weird uh management sim kick so
i'm super into that what you're
describing sounds quite different to be
fair yes well so
weed shop is like a good example of like
that kind of game but i would say it has
this like very kind of crude art style
and and and you know looks unpolished
uh arcade paradise
has a much stronger presentation way
more than i was expecting um it's so the
premise of the game is you are a
um
i think you're a girl named ashley they
don't actually specify your gender i
don't think but your name you're ashley
you are like a
a
college kid who like basically like
went to college for business management
dropped out and their dad who's like a
very successful businessman is like
look i'm gonna give you
this uh laundromat
that uh this was like my first job that
i owned and i'm gonna give it to you and
you have to run it to teach you how to
be an adult and and so at the beginning
of the game
you are just like running this
uh like shitty little laundromat like
right out of like a you know something
like uh i think
all at once i'm into this and at the
beginning it's like okay people give the
laundry you gotta like put it in you
wait for the timers and you're just like
very busy work but you find out that
there's a couple arcade machines in the
back and at the end of the first day
when you go and you like check the
coffers you know for the i think that's
what they're called right we're like all
the coins are kept sure um sounds about
right i feel like i've heard that word
before and your character is like
there is way more money in these arcade
machines than there are
from like
the
like the laundry and
like kind of like puts together like a
chart to like tell their dad like hey
like what if we invested more in these
like arcade machines and the dad's like
that stupid and silly like be an adult
video games are for children yes i'm a
businessman um
there's a they make a witcher joke where
his name is gerald
and and and apparently he's just all he
does is he hangs out on his yacht in the
riviera so he's gerald of the riviera
which i thought was funny
um
but then you like
uh also uh uh you manage and buy stuff
from like your computer which has this
like great like windows like 98 looking
like interface and you have like a i i
am text chat and you're text chatting
with your sister who works in city hall
and she's and she's like dude [ __ ] our
dad like he sucks
i had to get a real job because he
crushed my dreams so i'm gonna help you
out so she's like i can use my power in
the in the city to like you know if you
want like we could like get this
ordinance to help like knock down this
wall so we can increase the back room
and make it like an arcade okay so
insider corruption so you're basically
like without the dad's knowledge slowly
turning the back of this laundromat into
this like expanding arcade you start
like painting the walls and there's like
neon signs up um
i'm like
saving up money to get like the second
expansion to like turn the garage into
an even bigger part of the arcade and
you're like going on like um websites
and you're buying new arcade machines
and then it starts getting into the
management aspect where it's like you
can uh set the rate of how much the
arcade machines cost what difficulty
they're on
um there is a popularity associated with
the arcades and that increases the money
can you play the games you can play the
games oh that's cool fully playable
are they are they real arcade games or
like they're all fake arcade games but
they're all pretty good in my opinion
okay like there's like a pac-man clone
that's like a fusion of pac-man but with
like a gta aesthetic so you're like in a
city driving a car to pick up money
while the coke is like
top top down top down but if you get if
you get hit by the cops you don't die
instead you're on foot and the cops
start chasing you and you can like shoot
the cops to pacify them and you have to
try and run back to your car and then
you can keep going
what the [ __ ] but but then the game has
this like
crazy mechanic where at the same time
all this is happening you still have to
do the laundry job so you will like
set the laundry in go run over
grab all the money from the arcade
machines start doing an arcade machine
because you actually want to play the
games because um as you complete goals
in the games there'll be like little
mini challenges like hey get to level
five in this arcade game it'll add a
bonus that'll increase the popularity of
it which will get you more money from it
so you'll be like okay i got two minutes
before the next load of laundry goes i
need to go run over play a little bit of
this game because you don't want to let
the laundry sit too long because then
you'll lose uh you won't make as much
money from the laundry too and you just
need the laundry mat to make money to
buy more arcade machines at the
beginning like eventually i think it's
going to hit a point where you can get
the laundry laundry will become less
important but for in-game yes yeah so
i'll say that's kind of the one thing
about it is that
the laundry part does start to get very
drag yeah uh
repetitive i feel like there's going to
be a point where eventually i'm just
going to hire someone to take care of
all that for me like right now i can
hire a guy to like
um collect all like the money out of the
arcade machine if i want them though i
don't know man looks a little squirrely
uh here's what i'm gonna do jean-luc
when i get my steam deck yeah i'm gonna
play arcade paradise yes it runs great
on the steam deck i was really waiting
for you to explain what this game was
because they're like we have you ever
played arcade paradise you started
talking about laundry i'm like what but
no that's the game that's the game and
it's kind of like it looks great it's
got this great aesthetic um all the ui
is like very like pixel video gamey so
for example like every day at the
beginning you have to like pick up trash
um because people like just throw pizza
boxes in your filthy animals
but you want to do it because you
actually earn money from like picking it
up and throwing it away so you'll fill
up the laundry or fill the trash bag go
outside to throw it in the dumpster and
when you do there'll be this like little
like mini game where you like have to
like hit it at the right point and if
you do it'll like have this like
pixelated bullseye that you like throw
the
trash in and then it'll be like great
job you get 30 and you're like heck yeah
so it's like
what you get 30 dollars for just i i
think like the idea is it's like the
chara the the character you're playing
as is like
in their head like kind of like making
everything into like a video game so
that they don't get bored
like doing all this laundry [ __ ]
it's really cool it's it
did it come out this year yeah it came
out like a week ago okay it just came
out uh i think that's gonna be then it's
top ten december is that is that i
should play before
i mean i like it a lot because it's very
much my jam that's kind of a hard sell i
feel like for some people but it sounds
like just unique enough that it would be
something where like when in tw was it
2018 or 2019 when janae's like have you
heard of a game called plague tale and
it's like and it just snuck on to our
top ten so i it's gotta be gone i fought
pretty hard to get that yeah you you
fought you fought really hard to get
that on the top ten you went uh from
what i remember it was yeah jess and i
who like were like this game needs to be
there mm-hmm
but it really surprised me like just i i
was like heard about it and i was like
okay it seems cool but i was very
impressed with like how
polished it was
or it is
the writing i think is pretty sharp and
it's it's got some like
good sense of humor it's it's it's fun
and like i just will like have it on my
steam deck and be like i'll just play a
little bit of that so you're gonna put
it down when you get saints row yes
exactly okay yeah yeah it makes sense
yeah can you play saints row on the
steam deck
i i'm sure you could i mean are you good
yeah you should try actually
that would be a good video
it can you play something from the same
deck i wouldn't watch it so yeah maybe
that wouldn't be a good video yeah
i don't care
yeah exactly all the audiences why would
you want to it was an eight-minute video
of jake just like sitting there for
seven minutes being like am i really
about to download saints row hey i i'd
do it i'd do it if i had a steam deck
buy the steam deck i'm gonna do it but i
don't
gotta start that steam decker show
should have signed up just
to get a theme to it
um jordan do you wanna talk about a
court of fade and flowers uh we we i
don't know what this is and i was
curious so oh
i would say it's not it's not uh a game
it's um
i love watching this thing it's called a
dimension 20 which is like it's a show
where
dropout is the service that came out
from college humor for anyone who
remembers what college humor the youtube
channel was this is like their netflix
and one of
their exclusive shows is called
dimension 20 which is uh
they basically
do
d sessions and they have like a story
that's like in the realm of a tv show
where it's like there's going to be like
12 episodes of this and each one's going
to be like an hour and a half long
and so you can basically
watch this story uh play out and the
people that they bring on are usually
comedians or
like really good actors or people are
just really good at improv so like they
can carry the story in a way that like
normal people playing d d probably just
can't yeah yeah because they're just
really really good at it so the current
one uh a court of fey and flowers is
just this fantastic like bridgerton
pride and prejudice themed like thing
where a bunch of people are like playing
as fae and fairies and like they're
doing like tea and like gossiping about
each other so there's like very little
fighting it's more like how can you
outplay the other people in a term of
like social
intrigue but still using like the
traditional classes you'd find in dnd
and like
elden ring and dark souls were like
there's a rogue there's a
fighter and whatnot i've been
loving it because i really love the
movie pride and prejudice and bridgeton
is like delightfully sassy and
drama-filled filled
so this is like right up my alley but do
you play d at all i do play uh dnd i'm
not like one of someone who's been like
playing it like their entire life like
uh matt l frank i started in 2020 when
the pandemic hit and i was like what's
something that i can do that like takes
up a large period of time that can be
technically played remotely and people
were like you can technically play dnd
like remotely if you have like the right
uh software up i'm like cool
i've heard sessions of dnd are like two
to four hours long that's a great way to
waste like a [ __ ] ton of time so i i've
only been playing it for
two years now um but i
love it i
am in
three sessions currently uh two and wow
two and two in which i'm players one of
them is i'm playing with john luke and
lucy and tam uh and then the third one
is one that i'm dming so i'm trying to
make the story work and holy [ __ ] that's
hard like i thought i thought it would
be easier than what it was but i was
like holy [ __ ] there's so much like time
and management that you have to put in
you have to you basically have to
account because it's not a video game
where like there's hard rules in place
you have to account for the people who
are playing with you being able to do
practically
anything that they want where it's like
react to that yeah exactly and react to
that in like a satisfying way whether
like they're still having fun but you're
trying to like get them to the point in
the story so i basically have to say i'm
like here's the
beginning here's the conclusion and
here's like four points in the middle
that like they have to hit in order to
like learn the necessary
lore and character development to get to
this end point and anything between
those points can be anything but i just
have to like get them from point a to b
to c to d to e and then like
oh my god like people who do this
professionally or people who do this
just like all the time like hats off to
you because like the amount of like
acting chops and preparedness that you
need and like just an understanding of
the game mechanics is just
it's a lot
i so i was trying to get in d before the
pandemic
i had a game that i had started i think
we did one session it was like with max
scoville and like a couple other people
from ign and then the pandemic hit and
we're like we'll try to do it online
i'll resume never did it and then stop
but the one thing i was going to say is
that like
at
many like
my experience at obsidian was that
everyone was very into dnd
[Laughter]
not out of place but like
everyone had multiple dnd groups that
they would they would play with and i
was they're like you're interested in
joining and i was like this is too
overwhelming too many people are talking
about this i can't do it it's too much
i i'm withdrawing i'm withdrawing from
all these groups
as quickly as i can but i've always been
curious i mean
excuse me especially because like when
it comes to
video game writing right like dnd is so
influential to that especially rpgs and
stuff and you know i mean most game
writers
are dms yeah and and i think that's
fascinating that's kind of a something i
want to explore more at some point but
it seems like a whole thing yeah i did
play cyberpunk with the cyberpunk 2020
with the creator mike pondsmith that was
kind of cool
i think that's my thing is i would like
to branch off outside of d d
specifically because there are like so
many other
games that can like scratch that itch
but are maybe more
story focused or not as mechanic heavier
mechanically there's a lot of tabletop
rpgs
right like um
there's like a
isn't there like a
cthulhu one that's pretty good yeah uh
[ __ ] what is it called uh cthulhu's is
actually in the name but yeah there
because there's that there's uh
[ __ ] it's i think it's called kids on
brooms where
kids on brooms is like one of them where
it's like okay you have your like six
stats and each of your stats is just
attached to one of the six
dice
cthulhu call of duty oh yeah
i mean i googled that was the first
thing that came up so there's call of
cthulhu there's kids on brooms there's a
pen dragon there's a bunch of different
sci-fi ones um i know people like to
also make like
i feel like this is very popular during
like a peak tumbler era where people
would make like it's and d but it's all
adventure time characters or like
interesting stuff like that or harry
potter themed d and like that kind of
stuff i think it's easier also if you do
something like that to like
ground people in a world where like i
immediately understand like if someone
was like oh jordan you're going to play
a d campaign that's like set in the
world of like
i don't know the legend of zelda ocarina
of time like i know all the backstory i
could possibly need to like create a
character hold on let me let me pitch
you something
d and d button mass effect
i'm down
uh yeah that sounds pretty cool
yeah i don't understand everything yeah
exactly except for the mechanics but
yeah the world get it all like oh yeah
sorry how sorry approaches you at the
bar i'd be like i know exactly what
you're talking about then if it was like
a blood elf
i guess i know what that is i don't know
bad example but yeah yeah you play you
play enough like dark souls games and
witcher games too
most of the fantasy races are there's
there was like if you did like a mass
effect thing where it's like you're just
playing a sum squad on a different ship
like that's just parallel to shepard's
adventure exactly
universe
see that
i'm gonna start writing this
do
rpg that came out a couple years ago
that uh i think we were going to try but
pandemic once again happened like we
printed up same with cyberpunk gravity
yeah we were going to try it we were
going to try it right they sent me a
press copy of that and we printed it all
up we made this nice book and we're like
we're going to do this i like write a
good amount of it too pandemic is there
a blood-borne one or is it just or is
that no no there's dark souls one oh
dark souls one that i pre-ordered
bloodborne would be pretty good
bloodborne would be good too or was it
bloodborne i don't know i got a souls
like tabletop rpg and i was like this
would be the one i learned
and here we are
years later
d d but set in the fallout universe
sebastian o'brien that's a good one
that'd be pretty fun i mean like pretty
much any rpg i think you can just adapt
into a tabletop rpg
and like fallout falls perfect because
yeah oh yeah that you could literally
make whatever you want i mean that's
what like the best games of fallout are
it's like if we explored this no let's
do it and then it just oh yeah give me
like a d setting but i'm like
in new vegas like oh i'm [ __ ] set oh
that'd be so good
all right we should probably talk about
gamescom we've been going for about an
hour now and we listed a lot of games
here that we wanted to talk about um
i guess i'm just going to read them off
and then if there's something we want to
say we can say it if not
i'll move on fair enough the results
sounds good overall i would say that
show was
okay i think i think healy managed
expectations about like hey look this is
gonna be considering it had to fit
between summer game fest and the game
awards like later in the year this was
pretty good he's good he's good about
that even if the audience just does not
seem to understand it dude my favorite
moment or it was like any homeworld fans
here in the audience
and i was like
silence yes that made me laugh very hard
it was like okay
um
yeah i i don't know i i saw these takes
about like oh gamescom sucked and like
one night live and and like people have
weird i feel like i'm so removed from
this at this point because like when i
like when we cover these events i'm like
not i'm watching in terms of like oh
what we're gonna break out what we're
gonna pull but i have
the actual content of it just goes over
my head unless it's something i'm really
excited about so like i watched it and i
think my takeaway was there too many cg
trailers where it's like this tells me
nothing 100 about the game other than
tone which isn't always a bad thing but
like
don't don't show it i almost wonder if
he's saving the gameplay trailers for
the game awards like later no i mean i
think he's getting what they're giving
him that's also true some of these games
are a trend i've noticed recently this
happened both at summer games and this
is now they're like
okay they're kind of getting tired of
the cg trailers they want gameplay but
we don't have enough for a full gameplay
thing so we'll show the cg trailer and
then at the very end we'll show a quick
rapid fire yeah like two seconds of
gameplay there were several games that
did that and i was like
ah that's
still not what i want i will say not to
skip ahead but like when they showed
dead island to that cg trailer i was
like cool it's back i don't care it's
another as it's a siege it's the 30th
cgi trailer i've ever seen later
but then they showed gameplay and i was
like okay now i'm interested like i'll
play i'll check out that that felt that
felt like they made this lavish cg
trailer and then like someone either
keeley or someone else was like guys
it's been eight years it's been eight
years and the only thing we've shown is
another cg trailer we have to show you
yeah yeah we have to
like okay at gamescom like 2014 2015
yeah 2015 because i was like gamespot at
the time and getting footage from the uk
team of dead island 2 actual gameplay
people were playing that game really
yeah there there is there is gameplay of
a version of dead island 2 on
gamespot.com that's probably youtube.com
anywhere
i didn't even know that yeah there there
was footage in the wild people played it
i think that was when jaeger was
yeager was how um
lucy played it i'm pretty
sure know that
lucy what do you think what'd you think
of it at the time
okay you got to say something lucy
she's not saying anything all right
we're just
good
sorry everyone
uh
that joke didn't land at all
we'll go with it
um
but anyway we'll start at the very
beginning
and we'll we're going to skip a lot but
everywhere was the first thing i put
down uh
i am very curious
i'm gonna say not a good
trailer because it's not a good tr inc
and a confusing trailer a confusing
trailer but i think that's what makes it
interesting because it's like what did i
watch is this so it had all the like
elements where it was like
very cartoony looking and it's like oh
you're like driving around and now
you're shooting and it looks like
fortnight but then it like
and it then at the end it was like
it showed like for a brief moment like
this very realistic looking and then it
was like yeah because we want to do
stories too yeah and it's like what
could i tell if it was like dreams where
people are making their own games if it
was fortnite and mixing a bunch of
worlds together like in a ready player
one type of like scenario or whatever i
think is what it is like that's the
metaverse is that is it supposed to be a
metaverse game it's like i think it's an
nft metaverse game
i ain't gonna play that well yeah i mean
i i am curious about whatever it is just
because it's leslie benzies and like the
benz the benz i mean if you don't know
who he is he was one of the producers
for
a bunch of rockstar games i think most
famously uh when he split from rockstar
there was that email that went out that
was like we need the benz we need the
bands uh apparently fix red dead
redemption yeah apparently he was very
important to like the success of some of
those games from like getting them out
of the door yeah so i i i'm curious in
that sense because
the game seems unwieldy and confusing
and big but
i think there there could be something
really cool there
that said yeah it looked like an nft
game and i was like also they said it
was coming out next year
i feel like you would have more to show
well they said it would be playable next
year
oh is this a star feel situation or not
starfield uh star citizen star citizen
we're not going to see for a long time
but i think whatever they showed at the
first part that fortnight uh rocket
league stuff that'll be available will
probably be what people can everyone
wants to be that yeah and like
if people like that cool but like
i i
i'm curious for the story stuff like i i
think that could be interesting and i
will check that out even if that
normal game or whatever is is just nft
disaster we'll see
do you guys know that star citizen is 10
years old now that's wild i saw that
report that it's like the most
successful like kickstarter or something
like that i tried playing it like a
couple months ago yeah just trying to
jump just i started creating character
couldn't figure out how to open the door
and i was like okay i'm good
if i can't figure out the door i don't
want someone to cut that out of context
i did make it out of the door i walked
around a little bit did you see mark
hamill at all i didn't see mark hamill
is the single player even in the game
yet with him i don't know but i had 42.
i've seen footage of like mark hamill
and like a pilot thing yeah because they
were doing like a story mode
that was just wing commander this whole
thing was just supposed to be a
kickstarter for a new wing commander
look at it now
what the heck um
uh someone points out in chat who is it
canadian spoon says the icon um in the
title image for it looks like an nft
token it does it
i think someone posted one of the
job postings for working on this game is
like blockchain engineer or something
yeah if you look closely you can see
larry david
yeah well i mean
they're very smartly at least hiding
that as much as possible
uh callisto protocol i feel like i've
seen this game so many times i'm very
excited for it but i don't need to see
any more
i would agree it's weird yeah i would
agree it's like
not actually over like i don't think
they've actually shown too much
but if you've shown it to be like this
is
the dead space and the honor yeah
they've shown enough to be like i will
play your game i feel like the thing is
they're like we've got gameplay and it's
like two minutes of game play i'm like
okay yeah i either want to see more i
don't want to see anything at all at
this point sure even though i just said
i want to see
the only part that they showed in the
trailer that was like interesting was
like oh you can like stealth and like i
had more of a last of us feel than like
a dead space feel which isn't a bad
thing
i was like a little bit put off with
like that one gameplay segment where
he's like sliding through the water and
dodging the fans i'm like oh this is
like a little
action cinematic e for me but maybe this
is like a one and done moment and there
won't be how do you feel about dead
space two because dead space two had a
lot of moments like that yeah and i
didn't really like those how do you feel
about apex legends that's got a lot of
sliding in it
come on jordan bringing apex legends
into this conversation jordan if you
like sliding you have to like this game
your criticisms hold no water i'm sorry
[Laughter]
i love the very slow plotting of the
original dead space and how uncinematic
the first
yeah very weighty fair enough
i i get that i agree with you but again
we have we don't really know much about
anything of this game so this could have
been one of the things like yeah this is
going to happen once maybe twice in a
20-hour experience and i'm like well at
that point it doesn't even matter yeah
like yeah
i guess maybe to clarify maybe
i maybe
they haven't shown too much but i've
seen enough to know that i'm interested
and i don't know i
that first trailer i was like this seems
interesting and then i saw game plan i
was like yep i'm playing that and then
that's all i needed to see and now i
feel like every event is like we got
glenn scofield coming out and he's
waving specifically it's jeff keeley i
think jeff keeley knows that's like
people want to see that it's his
exciting game to pimp right now because
because it's like that's probably the
biggest game with ellen ring already
next to god of war
and sony's not going to give jeff keeley
god of war so he's like callister
protocol it is i'm gonna give buddy
buddy the last of us though they won't
give him last night he did he didn't
talk about laughter he did get that
bold of uh
sonic to just come out of the gate and
be like all these games trying to avoid
god of war guess what we're coming out
the same day like
why don't we just talk about sonic now
right
uh well actually we put entails from the
borderlands 2 but we can cut that
because if you want john luke you said
you might have something to say oh i
mean all i wanted to say about that was
uh i absolutely love tales from the
borderlands the original i think it is
uh one of telltale's best games
uh bar maybe the original season the
walking dead it's uh a
like just the writing is like impeccable
um so i've always wanted a sequel to it
that said this is made in-house by
gearbox not by telltale completely
different team i heard that they maybe
poached some of the original writers
yeah i think they got like three or four
people but
having played
tales from the borderlands and having
seen what they showed
did you get an impression because
i was i was unsure i it was kind of hard
for me to gauge
it felt off like it didn't feel quite
there for me it was it's kind of hard to
describe i think for one
uh i thought the voice acting was kind
of mixed the one of the voice actors in
particular i was like ooh those are not
good line dolls
[Music]
yeah his lines were like
kind of like ooh like you don't want to
do another take of that one um
but i like that it's like three
protagonists i like that the um cast
seems very different from what we're
used to from like tales and borderlands
and stuff like that um so they wanted to
basically separate this one from
every previous borderland and that's
cool like so there will be like some
callbacks of the first they should they
should recently they should reese in
there yeah but it's gonna be one of
those things where it's like you could
jump into this game and have not played
any of the previous borderlands games
which is cool so i'm i'm willing to go
in with open arms but um yeah that
trailer like didn't get me hyped the way
i would want it to and yeah i just seen
that first game was such a like weird
lightning in a bottle cause i remember
when that game got announced and was
coming out i was like really like
okay is that post pre-sequel or
uh
yes okay
yes that was post-pre-sequel
i couldn't remember if it was right
after borderlands 2 if it was right
after i think it's post-pre-sequel
because they used a lot of like
environment assets from the pre-sequel
um
all i just remember thing is like wow
telltale is doing a borderlands game way
better yeah no that's the thing like the
writing was like wow like
you actually made the borderlands
universe like super interesting and
compelling with good characters and yeah
that game felt like a weird lighting in
a bottle so it's it's just like uh
i hope they strike again but
got a little skeptical well now we can
talk about sonic frontiers
anyway moving on
2d levels where like sonic's like when
you're looking at sonic running from the
side i think they're very clear like
look it's not all this weird breath of
the wild like rails floating in mid-air
type thing there's some
traditional like sonic levels in here
too and i'm like did you did you see
i have twitter
someone like showed some footage of
um
uh this game sonic frontiers and then
showed footage of um i think it's like
sonic unleashed and the level design was
like almost beat for beat the same oh
like as someone who's played sonic
unleashed like it's and a little bit of
frontiers now because like the turn very
similar like
it wasn't just like oh you know like
because like sonic games on some levels
like yeah like there's going to be a
loop and there's going to be this and
like
jump pad jump pad and the camera is
going to go into first person i think
it's going to be chasing sonic or
whatever um but it was like
he turned at the same point and then the
loop was right after and i was like
ooh it definitely feels like they're
kind of like
not cutting corners because that feels
like too negative but like looking at
the previous games as like a means to
do these enclosed levels much faster so
they can focus on like the over yeah
world a bit more but we'll see
still
[ __ ] bold to be like we're gonna come
out the same day as god of war and also
that trailer had took itself incredibly
seriously in a way that i'm like
all right that's a choice guys sure i
don't know about that one
sonic's
sonic never works when he tries to take
itself seriously just refuse to write
sonic well when there's like all these
tv shows and comics that literally sonic
so and movies that have sonic written
very well sonic boom
the show not the game
is actually very well written and really
funny
for like
do that in a game yeah i was like okay i
have i have no stake in sonic i i loved
sonic adventure 2 battle on gamecube
because the chow garden
that's it i i remember my big shadow fan
yeah i love shadow uh i remember playing
sonic actually i remember playing the
shadow of the hedgehog game and then i
played
i played sonic heroes
and i couldn't stand either of those
game like these are not for me and then
i guess i played that was a turning
point first i played
a sonic game on the sega game gear
i don't remember what it was because it
was my friend's game gear was it the
game gear the color one yeah yeah i
played one on that and i was like this
is dope but i didn't have it so it might
have been i think they maybe ported like
sonic one or two to the game game i
think it was one team that like bioware
or someone worked on like some rpg
developer chronicles brother something
something
dark brotherhood
speaking of like rpg studios working on
weird ports did you know that cd projekt
red did a port of saints row two for pc
no [ __ ] way yeah but but they were at
the time yeah that port's not good
though it's not at all i have to like
people yeah the version sainsbury on pc
is broken so they had it they had a unit
for that it was called cd projekt black
i think okay uh look it up i think it's
sainsbury's
as soon as i typed in cd projekt red and
just did s it just immediately
autofilled scroll to report
it's like cd project where i did one of
the worst ports in pc gaming history
because they're like we got to work on
the witcher 2. yeah that was them paying
the bills yeah they're like we gotta
work on the witcher 2 we'll get this out
like does it even build
it's interesting anyway wow i didn't
know that goat simulator 3
looks cool not for me but yeah it looks
cool yeah moving on like fun high on
life
i've never been
less excited for a video game so i told
you guys before
i in that first reveal trailer i could
have sworn i heard tim robinson speak as
one of the guns that would make sense
and that is the only that that i'm well
you don't even know if he is in the game
you're basically i'm like ninety percent
sure
you're gonna play this game
like i officers but tim robinson is so
i'm not like disagreeing with you i
can't imagine like
justin and tim robinson don't know or
like they have to know each other and it
seems like that would be the obvious of
like tim robinson's hot right now we
gotta get him hit him in
he's he's done voice acting he voice
stacked uh shitty sonic
which is the funniest thing about that
that took me because i didn't see any
tweets or anything i just watched it i
was like what the heck they get him
um
that's the thing holding me through like
i i think the game looks colorful and
interesting but yeah after that trailer
i was like i don't want to listen to
these like i thought the gameplay just
didn't look very
fun yeah
i don't know i'm curious i i just want i
just i just want to hear i want the tim
robinson gun i want to hear all of his
jokes
move on you could wait like a week after
it comes out and probably watch all the
clips of it on youtube yeah oh yeah i'll
probably have to make that video so
so i'll have to play it and then put
that together actually that's a good
idea for video no one copy that
no one from other websites
gotham knights speaking of games that
have gotten a lot of violence
yeah
i don't remember it i watched it but i
don't remember it was a good one it was
like a good trailer it was only it's
it's significant to me more in that like
i feel like the marketing for that game
has been real like oof
for a while and like people have been
like wow this doesn't look that great
that like this trailer was like oh
okay like yeah i'm gonna do it i was
saying it all play faces in it harley's
in it like there's and it finally builds
off that first thing when there was that
very first reveal trailer where there
was like that mr freeze boss and they're
like just so you know there's going to
be other enemies in here and depending
on when you go after someone they might
be
really easy or they might be really hard
and people have been like well who's the
other people other than mr freeze like
okay it's harley quinn and clay face
yeah
so
more just like i'm i'm like very net
neutral in that game now where i'm like
okay i'm
i'm i'm excited to play it i like the
batman games um i'm still very
skeptical of like the overall like open
world like
combat
all that loot stuff looked bad and
uninteresting to me like i
i don't know about all that like the the
overall gameplay loop concerns me but
i'm only i'm like okay it looks like
there at least will be some like fun
enough story stuff that i'll have
hopefully a solid batman experience and
you'll be able to try it four days
earlier now oh yeah yeah excellent
that's it right four days earlier four
days like a friday to a tuesday yeah
that was weird i didn't even like
realize or tuesday to a friday i don't
know that like they moved it up until i
didn't know that sounds today
i is so out of it i'll play it when it
comes out i was just looking at that i'm
like why did they move it four days up
is it literally just because there's
four playable characters and they're
like this is one day per character oh
yeah wouldn't it be great if they had
moved it also to the date of god of war
or or delayed it four days
one day per character we want you to
think about all the characters on these
days
where wins meet
that game looked cool that was probably
the coolest thing i saw in my opinion
that looked really neat it looked like
um i have no idea what i watched but it
looked cool i mean it was basically like
chinese kind of assassin's creed ghost
issue that style of game um
but way more stylized way more stylized
you're running on water
that look cool you're doing like crazy
sick flips and like parkouring and stuff
like it specifically was the parkour
stuff that was like what if assassin's
creed but like you could just run up
walls of assassin's creed was brave
enough to do a mainland game in china
yeah it also looked very chinese in a
way where like like the music they
picked was just like
like very unconventional for like a
type of like music you would see on like
a reveal trailer for this kind of like
it it seemed uh cool to like be itself
as opposed to trying to like appeal to
like western audiences with like uh some
generic whatever music and i was like
cool like i all right like i'm into this
like
you're you seem like really committed to
like your aesthetic to the tone to like
the authenticity of like the setting and
you're really like like i'm into that i
wanna i would like to play this it seems
cool um as opposed to just like
as much as like you want like people
been asking for like hey ubisoft are you
ever gonna make like an assassin's creed
japan or china there's also that part of
me goes like
do i want ubisoft to do that are they
going to handle that well are they going
to nail that like i think the setting
would be like 2010's
yeah sure like the art design will
probably look pretty good you know the
rest of it like who knows so
even though i say that i would still
love it i was assassin's creed that's
fair
ubisoft was like by the way the next
assassin's creed game is in japan i'm
like cool that's another 60 bucks that
you've taken from it everyone's like
everyone's like we don't need it we got
go sushima and i agree but also if they
were like yeah we're finally doing japan
i'd be like
okay maybe i'm in maybe
one
but yeah it it looks pretty cool i think
it was the most
surprising announcement for me i would
say well dead island 2 was surprising
but not because i'm super interested in
it just because it was like [ __ ] okay
it's happening again but like i just
wasn't expecting it uh it seems unique
it seems interesting i think like
we don't get a lot of we don't see a lot
of games from china and i feel like
there is
interesting stuff being developed there
and it's cool that we're finally being
able to see that stuff like i don't know
if you guys played
[ __ ] what's it called
it came out last year it was kind of
like an earthboundy sort of game
what was it called no
i played a good amount of it was really
good um
sorry i don't know what you're talking
about
hold on
delta ruin episode two no no
what was it called
anyone in chat no you have a frying pan
you hit things with a frying pan oh pubg
yeah pubg that's it um but but no i mean
like and then there's gentian impact
right which gentian impact
people are very into
i am not
no but it was nice to see like kitchen
impact that game uh the star the eyes of
p like a bunch of is like is liza p
japan or is it
i don't know who's making eliza p okay
um but me the other mihoyo game uh was
revealed or they showed it off here star
or something it was nice to see games
included that weren't from
us canadian or
mostly european and
japan developers that they were
expanding to a bit other
places
i can't find this game i maybe i dreamed
it up
i oh god it's on my switch i almost
finished it and i had to stop but anyway
are you thinking of a game where you're
like playing as this dude and there's
like this girl yes it's that one okay i
cannot remember what it's called but it
was on my list for the longest time it's
it's quite good it's a little too long
um
i played like 25 hours 40 hours yeah
like 25 hours and i was like
this is really long
anyway um outlast trials
i put this one in because i'm curious um
i really like outlast i really like
whistleblower i was not a fan of outlast
2 so i'm with you
not good um but i think a lot has to do
with like the setting they picked yeah
they're going back to more of an outlast
one kind of vibe so
i feel more confident in this one well
it also like it seems very sawy like
you've got you've got it's got co-op
play with four people
it seems like a like horror escape room
game that you play with multiple people
which seems really cool to me i mean uh
what i thought i'm into that yeah yeah
like like that that
seems pretty cool uh
it i feel like it got announced a while
ago and then we didn't hear anything and
then we got another trailer i think
we're supposed to be able to play it
early next year there's supposed to be
more in october there's a beta this
october yeah so i'm super curious how
that shakes out um because
that idea sounds really cool yeah
um watching that trailer
that trailer is like crazy violent and i
was worried eastwood that's the game
there we go
thank you
i played like 25 hours i don't remember
the name of the game
uh that trailer was crazy violent and
just kind of made me be like
damn they can they can show this on this
like just like the amount of like
swearing like decapitation
discretion advice oh okay okay it just
it made me laugh because i was thinking
about how like games like manhunt back
in the day he's caused like such like
panic yeah and i'm like looking at this
and i'm like this is like a thousand
times worse than any investigator like
what we're going to see in that game
because you have to think like oh like
when they advertised whistleblower they
didn't have any of the scenes that
incorporated like the groom and when you
finally played that game and you saw
like the groom you're like
this is so [ __ ] up in a way that i am
deeply uncomfortable the groom is maybe
the most [ __ ] up one of the most
[ __ ] up things i've seen in the game
like damn i haven't played whistleblower
it's good it's a really good like was it
before outlast um it is a
uh no it's it's it's like a
dlc story expansion oh okay that you can
i think you can just play it like from
the menu on its own and it's basically
it's like a story that plays parallel
to outlast so it's like the opposite
yeah um there's several moments where
like you're looking outside the window
like oh that's weird the church is on
fire and it's like oh and the original
outlast the main character
it's really good i would say it's like
as strong if not stronger than the
original interesting yeah i played out
last i didn't play outlast two um
because i just heard it was like it's
not good
but yeah i mean
co-op saw outlast sounds pretty
interesting so i'm i'm i'm super curious
i'm into it
um other than that lies of p which i
think was one of the the bigger
show stoppers yeah
i think the closest i've seen to a game
like
trying to get like blood borney but in
its like own
way i mean so i like
we got some footage from the developers
that i like cut together um you can go
watch on youtube.com gamespot go check
it out
like and subscribe all that nonsense
um and uh it was like
one i mean they had like
here's the part where you slowly open
the double door animation to reveal the
wider world here's where i talk to a
window yeah yeah yes literally you go to
a window and there's a silhouette of a
woman she's like can you find my baby
and you're like oh my [ __ ] god like
they're
going so hard into like the bloodborne
aesthetic but in a way that i was like
but they're also kind of [ __ ] nailing
it like
people have tried to nail bloodborne in
the past and they have not
they they clearly have like the uh the
money and the production polish to like
back it up because like it looks really
good and like all the animations and the
combat they're showing like has that
like at least seeing it it'll be
different playing you know playing it's
got that weightiness it has that
weightiness it has that that certain
like excisiveness that decisiveness the
way like the animations like swing the
hits the way like the sound effect when
he like parries and blocks i was like
ooh that looks really satisfying in a
way that like a from software game is
that i think a lot of from software
clones like totally whiff
it's also just so interesting that
they're using a story that a lot of
people already kind of know the story
yeah and so it's like you're thinking
about him like well what part of this
scene in pinocchio will like be adapted
to fit like this very horrific it's very
uh american mcgee's alice you know
aren't there choices you can make today
and you can lie and not lie yes
basically it's like do you lie or do not
lie
i haven't read too much about this game
so this might actually be the thing but
i hope
the game is easier if you lie
right like that would be awesome right
it would be cool if like by lying you
got something from it but you know
right
yeah dishonored when you're like killing
everyone like it's easier than sneaking
past everyone but you get the really bad
ending but it's like you can lie here
and then the next boss fight's going to
be easier for some story i don't know
yeah story reasons and then like or you
could tell the truth but then that boss
fight's gonna be [ __ ] hard and that
would be cool i think yes i agree
because like they're clearly not gonna
go for the whole like his nose gets
bigger every time
although that would be very funny
if this releases four pc there will be a
mod that does that every time you lie
the character's nose oh
a hundred percent yes man i i wish the
nose would get longer i hope that's a
thing that'd be so much that's something
from software would do though right
maybe maybe i don't know but this isn't
from software
that's genuinely cool though is that
coming out this year or is that no i
don't think so i think it's early i
think it's gonna be early next year let
me guess is it in february i think every
other
february march like well yeah uh
although if you recall what february
march of 2022 was supposed to look like
and that didn't happen so like right
this says it's out uh yesterday but
that's clearly not right could you
imagine how wild that be if that game
was just like out right now uh tba oh
okay tba
it looks it looks really good though i'm
actually really super into it yeah
um
last one dead island too we already kind
of talked about it
cool
yeah it's kind of weird because i feel
like
some of the thunder of a dead island ii
has been stolen by the fact that
like they made dying light which was
like
okay this is kind of the spiritual
successor the evolution and it's a lot
better it's a lot better and then guess
what they made two of those in the time
between this game being announced and
finally coming out so not to say like it
couldn't
still have its place like you know like
dying light's pretty grim and serious so
like if they want to be a little more
tongue-in-cheek with it which is kind of
the vibe they're going for more colorful
like that could be fun but mechanically
i'm sort of like
yeah kind of dynamite kind of ate your
lunch and it has like hardcore in it if
i'm running
if i'm running around this game and i
can't parkour the way i can in dying
light i'm going to be like
like you know what i mean like
they got to bring something else to the
table i'm worried it's going to be a
metroid dread situation where i'm like
mentored isn't bad i did like the game
but i'm like between fusion and dread
there were so many really good
metroidvanias that by the time dread
came out i'm like it's okay it's not
fantastic
but it's like it's just okay and i'm
wrong but okay metroid dread is not
fantastic no i like metroid i
love metroid but favorite game a lot but
but i'll i'll agree with you in the fact
that i think there are
indie
metroidvanias that like specifically
capitalize on the
the the like open world exploration
venia aspect of super metroid better
than dread for me it was like the combat
in dread is what i actually really i i
guess it might have been expectation
because i was hoping when dread came
back it was gonna be one of those things
where i'm like oh you guys like
metroidvania like
part of that word has metroid in it sure
this should be like one of the best
versions of like what this style of game
is and it's not i get you because
they're not from it's not like from
software like we're just at the top all
the souls like wish that we they could
be us yeah we're getting a lot of people
in chat saying they're over zombies
yeah that has been a big thing for the
past like 10 years to be fair i feel
like i was over zombies 10 years ago
yeah like around the time like i feel
like
you know yeah like by the time like
dead rising came out i really said
something the people who made left 4
dead made like back for blood and i
played it for like a week and i'm like
you know what
that was already a little too much and i
don't want to go back and play anymore
yeah i i think for me like the last of
us was a pretty good capstone on the
zombie genre i'm like cool yeah we're
good that was it and then a million more
zombie games came out yeah
but yeah i don't know i
i was impressed by the gameplay of dying
light like it looked good sure it looks
polished
yeah i mean
it looks pretty like i like the setting
like this post-apocalyptic la or is it
is it technically la
i think they said they like took
inspirations from it but it's not like
actually
l.a yeah is it going to be an island is
it la but an island it has to be an
island it's called it's called
that island so it can't actually be los
angeles
but yeah i mean
i'll play it i'm curious i think
i like the idea of there being like six
different characters and i'm like oh
will you make it that if like my one of
the characters dies that they're not in
the story that could be that could be a
way it could separate itself from dying
lights dying light does have co-op um
but it was always like you're
the same person
co-op and it was good co-op like i had
fun playing uh dying light one a little
bit with you and matt and a little bit
of dying light too but i remember dead
island was like forgot that game came
out this year to be perfectly honest
yeah i really think that game came out
this year i knew that february i played
it and i was like this game is cool and
then i stopped and never played it since
i want to get back to it because i think
it's a solid game until the end yeah
that's that's how i feel about it i
don't know what happened in the end you
should literally just play until you get
to the part where you're like this feels
like it's getting close to the end and
then just stop playing you'll you'll
love the experience
i kind of want to watch the ending now
i don't know if it'll make any sense but
also it wouldn't make sense either way
it's yeah
all right
well that's gamescom uh some people
mentioned dune we didn't talk about dune
because it was a cgi trailer i don't
know a lot about it other than that it's
a it's made by the conan people it's an
mmo it's a it's a mmo survival
seems cool
i like the idea of a dune mmo like i
like the idea of playing like in that
world with other people yeah but i i
played it i don't know what the game
looks like yeah i played a bit of conan
um
conan wasn't it was not like that yeah
that kind of game's just not for me um
that kind of like perma-death crafting
yeah like i get the appeal but i think
what did it yeah i played like six hours
and i died to some coyotes and i was
like you know what i'm done that's it
like it's kind of going for like that
rest vibe almost in a way where i'm just
like
but doesn't have quite the like
weirdness of rust um at least yeah
that dong's though
yeah they had dogs so if they don't have
that game hung dong yeah i remember
we got in trouble because joey made a
dong montage when conan exiles we got in
trouble for that yeah he made a dong
montage on gamespot damn who got
who called us out on that that was a
great idea
this is funny though i think it was all
blurred too so yeah i was yeah okay
uh question of the week brought to you
by maria serious business in the game
spot discord make sure to join the game
spot discord if you haven't already you
can dm myself tomorrow lucy sean luke
jordan
no i'm maybe i'm in the discord but do
you want to be dmd about oh no
[Laughter]
so if you want to be in that discord
feel free to join you can add your
response to these weekly questions um
but here's the question in your opinion
which video game has the best fashion
persona 4 with its yasugami high school
uniforms and colorful costumes elden
ring with its various armor sets sable
with all its clothing collectibles
are they saying out of those games or
just like in i think in general those
are just examples yeah um are we gonna
go for a game that like you can
customize your appearance like uh saints
row gta are more like something like
dragon age or the witcher where like
people have like a sense of style it's
fashion so like not what you not what
character you can create but what you
can put on your character okay or or
like just the fashion in the game yeah i
would just say like immaculate fashion
so like even like if you have deep
customization if the options aren't good
looking then like god i love
bloodborne's outfits bloodborne's pretty
strong bloodborne's a pretty good one uh
um i absolutely love all the fashion and
uh vibes of splatoon i think oh yeah
that's like that's a good i think those
games have like excellent fashion um
super super good
um someone in here uh
mentions cyberpunk 2077. i liked the
fashion in that game until i didn't
because i had to switch my outfit to
something stupid because that was a
higher gear level yeah that kind of
loses some points for that yeah because
there were moments where i was like wow
i look [ __ ] cool and then like 10
minutes later i'd be wearing like pink
bunny ears and like
in my underwear because that's what the
best outfit i had was like like a
colorful suit and like okay which is
such a shame because you see other games
like
dark souls be like well you can mix and
match stuff but even when you mix and
match stuff it still manages to look
really cool and cohesive for the most
part i'm like
okay souls is real i will never
like equip my soul's character with
armor that's good i will only equip them
with armor absolutely that looks good
yes because
especially bloodborne because it's like
okay this is like 10 points better on
flame than yeah bloodborne they smartly
realized it does er the points kind of
matter but not really yeah
um
so
yeah
yeah
i would say um
i really like the
a lot of the armor design in uh
uh
destiny is really good um destiny is a
good also we didn't talk about it and we
don't have to go into it but uh that
destiny lightfall reveal
um was [ __ ] sick they're going for
uh 80s retro future like vaporwave
aesthetic uh so it's basically like what
if destiny but blood dragon and everyone
has a grappling hook now and i was like
here's my money bunji i was gonna give
it to you anyway but now i will next
year give it to you still so mad that
there's just like no easy way to get
into destiny 2. like the only way i can
get into there is there is well once
make john luke walk you through that's
like what i mean it's like the easy way
is to find someone and have that person
walk you through up to that i'm saying
like there's no easy way for me to just
turn on destiny 2
and try to figure out like what's
happening enough no to like get into the
game if i load into that game by myself
i'd be like i have no idea what to do
so so to be fair
you're right 100
they are actual part of the announcement
was they are working on new ways to do
that they're gonna have this like um
basically progression track that is
designed around new people joining in
and like being like hey you should try
doing this and you should try doing that
so it sounds like they are attempting to
address that which is cool um also uh i
guess this won't really be relevant by
the time this is out but um for like
this week since they announced it um
that game is entirely and all its
expansions are free uh on the epic game
store or i think just all platforms so
you can just like play all the
expansions and try it out if you want
yeah it's i guess it's more
one of those
things and this is totally off top we
don't have to go into it all that much
but it was like one of those things that
i remember playing
destiny 2 and then i
came back to destiny 2 like
months later which was a huge mistake
and like so many like things had changed
that i couldn't access certain missions
anymore and i didn't know why i couldn't
access them and i was like trying to
figure out like okay so what am i
supposed to do now and i was reading
guides and like trying to figure
everything out and like
it was just one of those things where
i'm like okay
clearly
destiny 2 is a game that is like best
designed when you're someone who has
been
like not playing it like every single
day but like been playing regular you
regularly check it no i i agree like i i
think
and it's it's partly because they just
keep updating that game like constantly
like in a good way like they have to
because the game gets stale or like hey
that wasn't working but it's like i
understand why they do it it's
it's like trying to jump into a tv show
in like season four without watching
totally seasons one through three and
being like yeah maybe i'll eventually
figure out what's going on yeah i hope
they i i do hope they address that it
sounds like they're trying to do that
from the gameplay standpoint story we'll
see
i don't think you can do it with the
story yeah i mean it would be very
helpful i've been playing it with jake
and i'm definitely walking you through
it mechanically i haven't tried to give
you guys the story spiel because i was
like i don't i don't care i don't know
it's like one
um this would be way too much and two i
don't think jake would care everyone
made fun of that wizard came from the
moon but literally every line of
dialogue feels like that
i have no idea what's going on this
sounds stupid as [ __ ] like the most was
like callie was like wait what's going
on here and i was like oh okay she asked
so i'll explain it but otherwise
i'll shut up um
i'll give a shout out to uh
channeling michael heim here final
fantasy 14 because there's some there's
some good fits in 14.
oh yeah you walk around like the the hub
areas don't they actually have fashion
shows
yeah
it's wild definitely some cool stuff
there uh
creed mentions animal crossing i think
animal crossings got it's like
simplistic but i think it i think it
works yes i think there's some there's
some cool styles you can have an animal
crossing
um i see
uh
i thought i saw world of warcraft oh no
it's like trying to keep up with world
of warcraft monster hunter also very
cool um if ben were here pants yup pants
you bring up how much work you got to do
to like get those pictures but that
makes the pants so much better does it
though
much of anything no
they're pretty once you get into late
game
the pants get the pants get good also
the most recent monster hunter that's
the name of this episode remember the
pants the pants get good the pants get
good
are you gonna say something no that's
fine all right
well i think we should probably wrap up
this episode of games but after dark
thank you all so much for tuning in and
if you want to join the discord be sure
to mention or uh message one of us on
twitter
um
not jordan though
he doesn't he doesn't want to talk to
you no he does not want to talk to you
because he's going to backfire and if
you're a message he's going to be like
hey you should play saints row you
should get saints row
right
anyway that's been episode 159 uh
jean-luc anything you're working on you
want to plug not really just working on
stuff on the background mostly nice
jordan i can't talk about any of things
i'm working on but things are being
worked on cool yeah i probably can't
either but uh
i guess early next week there might be
something aligning with the big game
coming out next month so you might want
to see that oh it's just about saying
like there's nothing coming out next
week what could you possibly be it's
next month but there's some there might
be some things that i'm working on that
show up next week
could be interesting
for some it also might get some gamers
heated but you know it's just how it is
sometimes the gamers love to get heated
yeah anyway
thank you all for tuning in and we will
see you next week tomorrow should be
back too bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you